hey bro hey hold on you're on the
podcast be respectful all right I didn't
ruin every right no but I was shooting
my show and I couldn't guarantee ten
o'clock and I got here at 10:30 I don't
believe I'm why you um today why don't
you go to the gym and workout only your
legs and do that for about grow huh
do you think it's because you've never
had any adversity in your life so you
never had to really worry about how to
how to root yourself to the ground
I know it's so they're not so I'm asking
seriously so your legs being that short
and skinny that's not a condition well
sometimes you don't get enough calcium
to one part of your body
rubbing milk on your legs is not how you
get calcium in your bones who talked to
you about nutrition who's the guy no
okay
Chris Gregg an expert I gave you guys
wings I got you up out of the nest it
was not comfortable at first but I got
you out of the nest and now you're
flying right yeah and now you're like no
no and I'm like don't do that you're
like are you a dragon I mean yeah you're
like I'm just like and you're like you
never say wait that's my that's the
noise and I'm just like that's me
are you guys some he's kicking he's
kicking everything my game with drones
you guys I wish you can see this he's
thank you
I know but people listening he's
reaching in the air the noise you make
is like this Oh
- what's a yearly jump your next special
that you never do should be called oh my
I have never been more insulted and I've
seen a lot of pictures of you sometimes
that on the internet when you're young
mmm when you didn't have a beard and
when you had short hair mm-hmm and it
was interesting because like that's the
guy with the lunch pail right what well
wait what well some people go through a
transition and what they do is they go
there's the guy you shove in the corner
okay I'm your lunch whatever it is right
or or let's just shove them around or or
you know what that's what they do right
ya know and then you get mad Namira you
I'm gonna change to any of your dad's
like let's get him a stylist and then he
got the Chagos Kroy your hair long cross
scruff and then reinvent yourself
because your name used to be Dennis
now it's Chris is that true no that's
not true my name was never Dennis it
could have been back then right all
right no it was not it couldn't have
been my name is Chris and only Chris hey
no no it's all good dude
let's go back to fun huh let's go back
you know you're talking to me the way I
talk to that door guy I'm saying hahaha
are you laughing in a good way or what
sly you see what happens is mmm blood
starts to boil yeah
blood starts to boil right these are
gonna see the bun I can see it and I
don't want to make [ __ ] I don't want
to make your body look like your bank
account which is whoa
dance okay okay Brian followed dance Cal
don't these because I could do my shows
and people go full of dead yeah maybe
you have called me sweet tart tart nasty
do you know how I'm not dude your next
looks don't take this the wrong way what
your neck looks oh no your eyes boy your
neck looks us unfortified I know
good so you let's say you know bro I'm
[ __ ] box anything for your legs ever
and we know that by SWAT and that's okay
I squat I squat every [ __ ] three four
days not just the bar do you squat
because your legs I can do 225 five
times probably not true right I've
worked very hard will you have new knees
and we know that your new eyes well your
your new knees have never been used so I
can see how you would bear some way what
are you talking about I have a new knee
we've never done anything with your legs
dude besides sit and stand ups no no no
no no I [ __ ] and impose I like going
to the gym I work out very hard I sweat
very hard and I [ __ ] and I burn
calories man I do an 80s workout you do
lat pull-downs and you don't do that
bench press on the and then you walk go
I'm not what are you doing hey hey hey
hey Brendon why are you doing a lot of
fighter in the kid dude I'm being
respectful don't [ __ ] around here
there's a lot of shitty [ __ ] there's a
candles we don't use there's some
letters on the ground ten like chin
[ __ ] a cleaning service signs on the
ground this place this place dead bird
down there yeah this place is not
remember last time let the hangover it
looks like like yeah I was in know you
were in you weren't in it I was three
guys were you I do that because I have
flames right here that can so that's
what's up so I go we've had literally
never spoken about that terrible no it's
not terrible [ __ ] amazing ok but why
did you go did you wake up and you were
like ok
Coffee and I'm tired of that I'm gonna
get flames on my hand
you got a key nothing allow you there's
nothing about you nothing
that would that would signify flame are
you [ __ ] out of your mind dude
what about you know what you're not your
dude I'm on that's right that's why
that's why I had to get it no don't say
I did don't fire don't do that okay but
that is like a terrible 80s run no not
and there's nothing about you that
sweetie
there's nothing there you are basically
low-energy all the toll [ __ ] your human
broccoli that's I'm not kidding no it's
mine to be that way but you you're for
you you're pale I'm good like you get a
nap all the time
nah bro I'm killing it what are you
doing on the phone so annoying
no don't do that yeah dude don't do that
don't snap snap [ __ ] don't stop no way
dude Terrell terrible way to introduce
you to them [ __ ] fingers so it
doesn't catch fire because I don't want
[ __ ] fire to catch see it's my garden
you're putting water I'm gonna get water
on this side I'm gonna go [ __ ] stop
it no stop it's not to get water on that
side they're not hot I am [ __ ] no why
did you get but why did you say let me
see that
okay it's so annoying Chris fire man on
fire like my last special to you you
don't get it it has layers do that on
your [ __ ] wrist that's the [ __ ]
layers
you got a sweet tartness as they drive
by I like it well don't be [ __ ] sweet
tart tart do-nothing sweet tart tart
about me at all I'm a [ __ ] hard older
dude yeah I've seen a lot of [ __ ] dude I
think it tight you know it's so
hilarious I was at [ __ ] Starbucks
getting my second coffee today yeah and
the guy goes like this I came in today
without laughing he goes he does Chris
what you are not a household name so
don't act like the [ __ ] guy at
Starbucks laughed and he played it good
he was like what and I go like this I go
like this I looked at him and I go like
this
Chris yeah people actually I have family
members who go what's that guy crystally
delial I know they do so your name is
not because they have a listening
problem and not hearing problem now
what's that guy Chris D'Elia like dude
and then what some people go they don't
do that I just heard famous they don't
do that dude
they go yes you to know something and I
mean this so seriously and so sincerely
I'm gonna say thank you I took a nap a
Rip Van Winkle nap for five years I woke
up with my hair way too long my nails
way too long and my [ __ ] beard way
hydrated and D hide some in question
behind okay on me up after my Rip Van
Winkle nap you've been training
I mean training yeah I mean so can your
shirt in your shorts and your undies
every single [ __ ] bag right
you still beam them up B you don't last
one round bro you understand me I'm
talking about I didn't cut my nails and
I can't make a fist I be he did do Jiu
Jitsu for pleasure no no Chris did I
know he did for six years and I want to
say this [ __ ] you what [ __ ] your [ __ ]
oh wow Jiu Jitsu okay if you know step
to me when you're at home is that that's
not my dude I turn my [ __ ] off yours
brother
dude don't mind I don't like how you say
bro after that and that's your phone you
know why because you're [ __ ] terrible
with your phone no cuz cuz I keep things
quiet right well although he's Jenkins
texting are you gonna wear those
sunglasses the whole time you know what
I don't even realize when they're on or
off anymore what does that mean cuz you
know why because my my life is that cool
okay so when I have sunglasses on
indoors I don't realize it okay so I
want to ask you something
yo don't do that go ahead shoot ponder
you you are welcome to welcome to fight
or in the kid yes I know
Krystal E is guesting yeah well is it
get well looks like miss su mo first of
all your shoes make you
those are lips obviously they're gnarly
outside of dude I'm six-two well they're
not their air maxes dude you're acting
like they're [ __ ] well and they're
gold right their gold yeah well they're
matte they're like you know the in a
stock's don't go I don't care cuz I'm
not in the fashion that's obvious slam
you start out with a [ __ ] Grand Slam
not a slam hey man we got a bunch of
[ __ ] specials here at Denny's but you
just wanted the good old-fashioned Grand
Slam that's not that wasn't a slam and
your mouth is twisted in such a
disrespectful manner no the first thing
I want to say is okay what pick a shade
man pick a shade with that like a shitty
Crayola note why are you dressed like
Chris Gaines attend you know when Garth
Brooks wears the time different color
Church it'll be green here on one side
and then black on one side you do
anything I don't mean to open up the
[ __ ] I don't mean to open up the show
with a huge move like that but no people
I made I knocking swear just get that
because it's he look like an actor from
American Pie oh dude holder's dude it
looks you got that for free that's such
as that's such a [ __ ] I did get it
for free look man dude that's such a
hoodie you'd wear God or free would not
buy that you never got that [ __ ]
shades off right now senses know why I
gotta wear these dude mmm
futures to brown live on pancakes bro
what do you bro you you can finish your
pancakes last night no I only have got
that pancakes yeah I had a one butter
okay
swingers they got nice buttermilk
pancakes shut up who says buttermilk
pancakes just say pancakes yeah well no
yes unless they're like banana nut
pancakes because his blueberry but
standard yeah pancakes they oh my god I
like when they say when they say
buttermilk it turns me it gets me going
like now you go to swingers every night
right a lot yeah and you you find a
corner and you eat I don't need people
to be lining up but I don't care I'm
kidding no you did shut down Starbucks
my nephew called me and said hey Chris
D'Elia just walked in to mossy itza and
he's alone and I went yeah of course
he's alone cuz he's a weird went in by
you ate dinner by yourself and they go
yeah bro look at me
you serial killer or or you loser
no since one of the sushi bro did you
have some soup and rice
what do you don't eat raw fish yes you
do do you do what are you saying man did
you order a mustard turkey sandwich
that's what you eat you ate sushi why
were you there by yourself dude I
[ __ ] you know what I do what not only
do I do I not invite anyone I send a
text out and I say I'm getting sushi
no one's invited and then I go by myself
you know why dude because I [ __ ] up
here bro hey I got his [ __ ] blast can
you do that
blast I have a blast dude I just think
anything I want nobody's there to
[ __ ] be like ah but also [ __ ] them
dude I just chill you're right hang out
I have a good time and I eat sushi and I
go like this and I think about stuff
what do you talk about lash to do what
do you think about like seriously um I
think about like the people around you
and if someone Falls and that would be
funny or like I'll think about something
I could talk about on stage or I think
that your mix you're probably mixed
somewhere you are you from the future
dude what the [ __ ] are you from the
future
by 2018 [ __ ] dude right ha cheers you
guys
you guys want me to tell you what
happens yes okay what happens to me and
Brian in the future troll hole no say
that I'm [ __ ] or I'm bust and with
creativity right now what they do put
the douche out there Brian can you
please do 30 minutes that's too long for
the comments don't we don't care we
don't care well no he sees the future
Rogan was like hey the crowds kind of
tough you know I was like I went mm-hmm
you did that yeah did you say they were
tough for everybody and I was like
that's really obnoxious let me close
this bad boy out and actually did have a
really great set last night you really
really did yeah and it bugged me why I
want you to fail I'm just gonna come out
and say it I don't care don't you you
like when Brian I like when I like when
my friends fail hey Bros me room to ride
today I'm gonna do a video I want them
to not know why I'd rather them stay
home and watch my Netflix special no one
of them what did he so if my if my if
it's empty there are six people
what is your face gonna be like
Oh for my hey Chris you call me up yeah
hey man hey how'd it go what happened
with the show only it's so annoying I'm
so funny I'm like 16 people were in the
audience all right no yeah that's so
well yeah and you know you'll be able to
tomorrow's not selling well either what
are you doing nothing what are you
breathing uh I was I'm cold it's cold
outside so I mean I hope Saturday's big
I hope so
yeah oh I'll tell you what I'm gonna do
okay I'm gonna take your brother who's a
smartass that sends me texts yeah like
open for me on the road I'm doing
stand-up now [ __ ] like my brother says
that yeah he says [ __ ] like that it's
nice just send me a picture of him
smiling I'm gonna smack him around with
an open hand for no reason I'm gonna
bully him push him down push him into
the bush it's no dude yeah imma get his
get his knees all scraped up dude and
you're gonna sit and watch and all
you're gonna do is go don't know look
dawg I'm not gonna do that
don't and I'm not gonna listen no I'm
gonna I'm gonna shove your brother
around make him cry and I'm gonna get if
he has money in his pockets I'm gonna
reach in his pockets I'm gonna pull out
the money I'm take his keys mmm throws
keys somewhere for no reason well so I'm
gonna bully I know you're not gonna do
you ain't gonna do jack
no dude right that's not true you're
gonna do [ __ ] chow dude I'm done
imposing the will honor all right on my
yeah okay
dolia sure come up I'm gonna chest-bump
you know mannose gonna be on your nose
you can smell my breath okay and I'm
gonna go what right no no you're not no
you're not you're gonna go and you're
gonna fall on your brother I'm not keep
and weep with him and you guys gonna
clutch each other
mmm cry and then you know what's gonna
happen I'm gonna fun Oh
peel out no your car No
then you're gonna pop up and you're
gonna say that's what you're getting
hey Cryptkeeper I go like this a gist
humor you don't text while you're doing
our podcast yeah I do dude I was texting
to get me a tea
call me with an emergency I sent it to
so many people look at your shitty
posture stats place man hole trainer
wouldn't appreciate out sit like this to
like hey did you try that hey Chris did
you train a have you on a diet - yeah
dude I ate so many [ __ ] ice creams
last night why wanted why wanted that my
mind when I get when I when I when I get
a boner I faint a lot cuz of the bad
blood hey lose a lot of blood about it
yeah I just oh you are okay is that a
sundial they go like hey no oh no can I
ask you a question
maybe so you are are you anemic dude
because I might color you have you know
what it is no alabaster why it's not
it's porcelain white yeah is what it is
in it but it's it's very a lot of kings
and queens are that because they don't
go because of the workers go outside so
you don't you don't really see the Sun
it'll work it's good have you had your
vitamin D checked no I go I went I was
in the Sun thank you like you know
you asking me a question right yeah try
to answer it sorry bro
sorry man it's all good but we made a
mistake together right right well yeah I
guess all right cool
cuz I was answering a question you
interrupted me so we made a mistake
together right yeah yeah okay
celebrities 100% who's the most famous
celebrity you've had reach out to you
Christ
okay like I don't know that's Christ
true Christ What did he say he goes like
this
thank you for taking what I've given you
and putting it you know exponentially
into the world he goes like this fine
even I even the all-seer even I didn't
have any idea that you could take it
this far he goes like that so he was
singing the way they do like yes yes I
don't know and it was like when I
originally put you on this earth I
didn't think that you would exceed my
expectations but you did
he goes like that it's like what that's
incredible yeah I mean you bestow
anything any rewards so yeah he gave me
these because he was like here are some
glasses because you're going since your
faces in the front of you and the past
is behind you and the future is way far
ahead it's gonna get shiny and bright
and you need these sunglasses to shield
your vision so he gave me these
sunglasses that's a main I know he's
[ __ ] weird if you know did he say
anything about the fact that I'll be in
or latter days to take is it going Super
Saturday practically nothing what he
said was if you're a fan of Christmas
Chris D'Elia definitely go outside of
the Orlando Improv and pick it that
Brian counts going to be there that's
what they said right said yeah Christ
say I didn't say why I think Allen is my
face no no it's like this if you need
supplies I've got markers and
whiteboards does he make but so follow
me oh no he go he said he said fellow
well now are you your hair and it's okay
but you are losing your [ __ ] hair oh
that's funny don't don't come in from
you hey I'm the ocean glass of water
why are you so wet at a Terrell annoying
hey I'm a [ __ ] forest fire matches
what the [ __ ] are you doing alright
I have some hair I'm follicly challenged
on lie down
don't lie don't like that bro get up hey
real quick Chris are those jeans or
sweats these are [ __ ]
both bro I do hybrid yeah pick get out
yeah ginger sweats
you know it's [ __ ] up I had a great
drop in knowledge but it's not my phone
my phone just died I'm so disrespectful
all right let's wrap this on black guys
yeah there's no great dropping knowledge
shut the [ __ ] up hey I'm smarter [ __ ]
dropping knowledge ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for crispy well thanks
for come on what you guys doing listen
to what's he called congratulations
iTunes everywhere he's out of his garage
with his hot dog with his [ __ ] hey
can't be a guest on congratulations I'll
have to check on what I decided
complete waste of time
can't do it I'm booked you're off booked
with who you me I got me on it tender
knees not hey ho yo food was in the way
dude hey these shoes are white shoes why
do they shot the [ __ ] scenes in Game
of Thrones we're [ __ ] Jon Snow is
right around the mountains on these
shoes and you're gonna step on them I
they were in the way I apologize I
didn't mean to step on you can crochet
something nice about me okay please
Chris I think what they're shutting you
out of rapper stuck your [ __ ] foot
before yeah oh yeah you guys [ __ ]
sabotage me dude this was on the ground
already we did not stop you what is that
Laffy Taffy bro it's a [ __ ] it's a
water bottle leaders don't date the
co-leaders take themselves very
seriously and they take and they get
really mad at any slight you see what's
happening with you guys put hoursa
sabotage me and made me look stupid we
did it Chris nobody did that you guys
did do that see what pattern and
honestly if we were if we were chilling
outside you'd have to go back to the LA
Kevin and do some chores you do have
punishment well it's not punishment it's
just help you're helping now you're a
sweeper I'm a sweeper here you go any
bold landscaping duty so say something
nice okay about day and then all right
Anna be genuine all right and it better
be positive Chris I like Brendan's
attitude I think he's got a great
attitude and I think he's a go-getter
I think he [ __ ] won't stop and he's a
[ __ ] juggernaut
thanks man no problem in many sense of
the word - juggernaut yeah he's a
juggernaut okay great yeah good stuff
talk about me
yeah you honestly know be nice Chris I'm
gonna positive I'm gonna be positive day
remember that time we went to dinner
with a bunch of people and we were at
this restaurant
Laurel tavern or Laurel something sure
more hard we were hardware that's what
sure I think I was there right yeah you
were okay and Bryan at the end of the
meal I Steve nice meal nice to me a lot
of friends a lot of laughs yeah
Bryan says hey to me he says secretly
pay for this whole meal that's and it
was nice that you thought of everyone
else that we should that should be taken
care of okay well I do remember that any
cake
that's not very I don't know if it's
positive because I'm not is negative
being a dick
no but it happened I was there that did
happen
yeah Bryan was like offering what if he
was trying to don't know because you
were poor yeah yo people we bear I've
never met it was because you were
bragging about all your money and I
thought maybe you should put your money
where your mouth is and I hate for it
because you bragging I barely ate
anything I did I paid for it and didn't
make a den but I just thought it was
nice no no you know how be it was so
happy with yourself bro don't say hi I
know dude we ordered a lot of food at a
very nice place good wine and good wine
I don't even drink yeah you suggested
that I pay for everyone right and I did
okay okay and the interesting thing
about that is okay it didn't make a dent
right right now right now it didn't make
it didn't make a dent right but it
bothered you it's so obnoxious I was
listeners rightly so because you're
bragging about the money you make it's
so obnoxious but because it can all be
taken away from you as you said that you
are like boxing and sparring yeah you're
getting hit in the head sometimes that's
a real bad idea for you
it's a piercing to be on it gets him
really angry I mean you have you know
well okay why is it get you angry it
doesn't get me angry I don't like to
hear I just don't get why you want to
get hit in the head especially if he
wanted to talk to me he gets so mad he's
like I'm not even talking to you about
this no I wasn't he won't I'll ask him a
question like a technique question he's
like I'm not answering I'm not talking I
get that my brother Tyrell I get why he
wouldn't want it doesn't matter yeah
yeah it's like right I remember I got
embarrassed with him because I said I
said should I get the plant protein of
the whey protein in my smoothie and he
looks at me goes it doesn't matter does
it though yeah [ __ ] I'll never ask
[ __ ] dumb questions like that hey now
you can't get you under fifty oh you're
not getting here in the heaven in the
heck dude a schism I'm really young yeah
well you're 30 very young I'm yeah but
and you look 37 right you know I'm
saying not to be a dick but you know
that right
you look 30 you see every minute 30 tell
you a one that you are chock-full you're
you're 37 cup is chock full to the brim
you're spilling oh I get this load times
40 like that mix of course would you say
of course you're you for today I turned
38 how old will I look I'll tell you
this you I don't yeah when you're 38 the
day to 38 you'll look 38 okay
you're breathing it like it's a bad
thing I'm just saying that it and it is
the way you're saying it is a bad thing
and it's making me angry no I don't 338
for a long time I just turned 37 but you
got to stop saying that no I know but
you could mule you could mule drugs in
those [ __ ] eyelids you could mule
drugs in those saggy that's why I showed
you your eyes man
all right oh no you're making me sad I
know and don't cut your hair because
there goes that career no dude I'm up on
meth every day that'll be less
detrimental to your career I probably
have to [ __ ] cut my hair soon do some
kind of [ __ ] cool part probably okay
some they'll probably make your all
asked me to do so dragon what's in a
with you in a wheelchair in five years
I'm into longevity drugs that's my new
thing now oh cool cool do you still have
psoriasis I don't oh cool well wonder
what you're gonna get now just trying
some new [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll put up in
cinemate on and I give ish I'll take it
I'll take it somebody goes like this you
know Brian I got this new I got what is
it - give it to me
don't be a car you go like this guy goes
hey I got this new and you up yep and
the guy goes plunk and your body goes
one of those rumors no [ __ ] whatever
yes rice rice tentacles are you you dude
psoriasis remember we were just talking
about that all right what happened with
Brian the guy that we were just talking
to I don't know you switched your body
switch to someone else that's the only
thing that makes sense how did you get
lost in one sentence
man you're gonna be a really bad father
no I'm not do it my kids are gonna be
this [ __ ] bro they're gonna be like
whatever daddy we do not want to make a
mistake help me a memory it was a math
problem all right ready okay huh what's
wrong what's wrong I don't know why not
what is it four times a what four times
a well how many times well you know what
eight is yeah all right
what's that twice what's eight twice you
can't eat they have that feature now but
only for their blocker yeah rights
people no no I don't hate people but
you're you'd be good used to this
because when you're you often in a room
with quiet people like your shows at the
Orlando Improv yeah and another said
quiet that's right but make that what
I'm saying do you do you have do you
have an option because what I was did
they get this from you do you have an
option on your shows to go to the quiet
shows cuz when I go and I look at you
doing a stand-up not it's not very loud
right now you're talking
but other people are kind of more it's
like it's a TED talk I want to snow or
no kind of a library there are there are
moments in my show right where okay so
have you ever heard of have you ever
heard of the factor have you heard of
that so do some that's when you're all
you go okay so there's a moment where
there's a respite okay I mean no--don't
it words like that when the storm rings
you're okay in the storm right in the
tempest yeah no I'll give you a harbor
sometimes I hate you as some [ __ ] where
you just go they've never even heard
that I heard is that it's called there's
a certain what Brian joke is I think
that no I think I think that there's
I've had a lot of critics who really
know the difference say there is a
majesty to his performance I'm gonna
Google those words in quotes and Bryan
Callen and nothing will come out as a
majesty but so majesty but the thing is
but the thing is when most of your
comedy show would have that quote
unquote
off actor right where's the laughs right
so when I walked into a room what's up
what's up now what's that little boy
what was that little boy no quiet you
quiet
you owe me be quiet wide cuz I should be
in your audience that one was extra that
was a hard slam welcome to Denny's
what's now you owe me to 298 that was an
all-american slam no I'm not giving you
tonight can I get you anything else no
listen listen hey look it's a picture of
Brian in his career so so what's the
deal what what is um what's this what
another picture oh that's the chick I
thought I'm sorry I thought that would
no I thought that was a picture there I
thought it's a picture you and your
career
that's me syphilis a slippery slope
Chris we're supposed to make this
apologize and that's why I give you guys
certificate you didn't bring [ __ ]
but what are you growing on your face
honestly you know what I tell Bo beard
no no it's a hobo no it's not why
wouldn't you shave just your neck it's
politically incorrect to call the Mahal
Bo well I don't give a [ __ ] cuz you look
like a hobo
all the time no you would look like a
junkie no I know that no you know
whatever you know in my cult you don't
shave you just let it happen when was
the last time all [ __ ] aside your
skin saw the Sun 2015 there's not a lot
of death come on
what are you tired you if I drew a
[ __ ] picture of your brain coffee
hanging out and with my sidekicks and
chicks and chicks man lazy lazy day all
I think you're a book if we're all books
here Chris is a comic yeah is that fair
well good comic book so graphic novel
yeah okay dude I mean The Watchmen okay
my little Watchmen No am I your
superhero what do you think seriously
what do you think you would be the sloth
no do you know what I have a superpower
what I can open up doors without even
touching them how at the grocery store
Oh Brian didn't get the job oh how do
you do that he says I do it because my
fans open the doors for me dude your
fans don't travel with you around that
you've seen that uh you know what my
fans are there they and I'm not trying
to be a dick to you and no no listen
every time you say that it's dead no no
but let me just explain what my fans are
and it's no big deal and I don't give a
[ __ ] and I mean I didn't want to say
this out loud because I don't care but
I'll say it just for argument's sake
let's have a conversation
so my fans our fans what we would call
fans in life right now hold on it's just
that there's there's cuz I'm always
evolving and always like challenging
argument this guy teaches me teaches and
then you your fans are as we know and
again who cares who cares what your fans
are some are not yet in high school and
others are in high school right
not in those rooms and credibly fickle
so great they also refer themselves as
babies they come hell you know in our
fan bases what tea fat cake hey would
you [ __ ] hey hey hey Chris butt chin
disappeared when he went like that I'm
not yeah I can't wow you're just no
cheer Oh bro bro you human bird we are
uh we are [ __ ] twenty we are thirty
we are 40 or 50 my god your babies dude
what [ __ ] why you pay this because dude
[ __ ] this alpha secretly beta [ __ ] bro I
got it all figured out man calm down
I'll do what I want and it'll be fine
and because you're a buddy everyone's
fight oh we're gonna do [ __ ] you know
what I mean no you're not saying
anything you know what I mean how about
this man see what this man what number
one guest on fighter in the kid oh dude
hey people say forget though okay Will
Sasso Michael Rapaport yeah make way for
[ __ ] freak punch
that's hey you showed me your body
yesterday pretty damn good right no I
don't think so what okay
did you see the [ __ ] region look at you
I'm great no I'm just got your this I
think imagine what it's like listen you
had the lanky bird look at you you're
you you have I haven't had to fart this
whole time but if I did I would have
done it Wow Chris you have to have more
respect for our space and for this very
amazing part I like the way you're
sitting bro yeah I got I said dude when
I saw a Bon Jovi yeah when I was a kid I
was like that's how I want to sit and I
want to take it up an excellent have you
ever had a sip of alcohol no never a sip
yeah like communion or whatever what a
[ __ ]
so you and have you ever smoked
nope never see I thought for when I
first met you I was like damn Chris
obviously does drunk yeah Bobby looks
like an alcohol no I just say no cuz
you're a little bit sporadic all the
time yeah I'm not interested in what
they're saying that's why it seems like
that that makes sense okay you want coke
I'm like no you're just boring a [ __ ]
yeah we're just boring and I'm thinking
about spaceships or something gonna be
more interesting I'm not on coke be more
interesting how about that that why are
you looking around cuz you're boring and
you're you know what I mean or like you
should go to the when you go to the hair
cut place yeah do you say give me the
Jimmy Neutron do you say that word for
work what do you say I want this and
then show them a picture of the back of
a ducks water on my front is that what
you do dude Hey look [ __ ] Ace Ventura
son okay I do but I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna get it dude why
is it doing that today I don't like it I
tried and trim it down yesterday and now
I'm feeling a little self don't you
touches so I use mates it why do you
like this I straining your hair why do
you do like this like you're felling
like you're picking up because you're
watching it's it's fine dude it's it's
fine don't piss me off okay man you seem
really on that only way is if he
attacked you and I you're useless no no
dude I'm not you're truly useless
I'm very honestly you know what I swear
to God I'm not trying to be a dick
you are as useful as the couch like if
the couch was in the room or Chris is in
the room let me tell you something if I
need a help in fighting Brennan a life
in that location you would you're you're
basically a soft man no but I have a
counterpoint does a couch get hurt what
does a couch get you know what he can do
do you know D kill me and just ignore
you and you dude you to be a simpering
Shh [ __ ] pile in the corner not true
dude hey hey hey dude I don't rate for
six dollars lie down and I do it I want
that's the thing hedonistic hedonistic
lifestyle dude I don't give a [ __ ] what
you want me to do I'll sit how I want
and I'll do it
anywhere I'll be in court sit like this
I don't get listen sit up or I'm gonna
I'm gonna come out here oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what you tried to kiss me no that's your
you're trying to kiss me
oh that's how you defend yourself I know
I just thought about the people only
listening and not seeing it that you
that's your defense against a
male-on-male attack oh dude you just
alright let's see what else I can't even
York you're going Newland you're trying
to kiss me and your hands are all soft
oh wow that's how you defend your
salary's lotion have some self-respect
and defend yourself yeah your way God
hey hey hey you should see how he
defends himself watch this no I don't
want to watch me come at him it's not
bad see and that's why are you out of
breath row you got a bum ticker widen I
ran back what'd you do [ __ ] strength
training he's been running you smiling
what are you been wrestling do did you
get high no I have a jump in there man
Oh bye bye bye man smoke crack oh no
it's awful man I didn't take dance I
know it was [ __ ] well tell but you
took you took voice does this answer
your question
remember when you and I tried to sing
serious yeah yeah and we started
laughing Brian does that Brian likes to
relive the glory days he doesn't have a
bright future that's not true you've got
a checkered past
well that's [ __ ] true in a bad way
I've got kids I don't know about
and if I find out I like know them
anyway yeah cuz I'm selfish [ __ ]
selfish yeah so it's been 11 on but then
Israel and Lebanon had blood she's not
just Israeli she was part of their
Israeli Defense Forces
died two years all women are yeah in
Israel it's mandatory she's a big women
and men she's obviously hey for you know
you know what now what do you say it I
wouldn't she wouldn't throw your Wow
your aces leaving war
what are you sued be [ __ ] you what
bro not for you hey stand down boy dude
boy Stan hey bro hey no water seed with
caution
nah you know what bro how about this man
I don't even [ __ ] bro I [ __ ] make
sweet love I swear to god man not don't
you think your [ __ ] [ __ ] mail
stuff I push slow and I'm nice about it
man yeah well I don't policy I push that
what she's looking for
yeah she is right you know I'll tell you
that's Wonder Woman I don't want to give
girls what they look for I want to give
girls what they owe in a way I think the
first real athlete thank you - look dude
hey I was talking about Brendan oh well
no because I've got this trainer and
[ __ ]
don't say that don't say thank you
apologize I don't know what you were say
okay go ahead
he's the first he's the first real
athlete 0:02
to actually kind of be doing stand-up on
this level and the beat
well I think the ball is just like what
I think both of us just like we zero in
on something you are not gonna you're
not an athlete did you ever do any
sports besides you Jitsu blue belt and
stay there
what are we sports what's wrong with the
racket racket with one little rat is
like the rack is that big risk
no bad
badminton is actually shut up though you
know I mean you don't even have to say
Sofia Vergara's so shut the [ __ ] up you
call him Brandon
so should I do this this guy in Italy
who was I guess Iranian not yeah dude
[ __ ] yeah I respect that [ __ ] now Ted
you'll touch your face when everyone
don't do that thank you 100 pounds on
you you're 130
I'm 170 and I'm scrappy as all [ __ ]
get out don't say I'm starbursts and
I'll be honest [ __ ] ball ask me how I do
against Brennan ask me how I do but be
honest I do watch this and let this is
how I answer all about what like I if I
say how would you do against Brennan in
a fight how would you do against Brennan
in a fight keep busy how do I know what
that means
yeah because he'd be with the police
filling out a report busy eating your
ass yeah it sounds dude a new term like
well I say yeah I like it I like it as a
matter of fact it's the rapper's
sometime like cannabis said I could you
know I can't say the n-word but he says
I can eat my ass like you know it is not
it's not a I can't say the n-word yeah
that's what the lyric bill Morgan its
nutmeg that's what he says I asked at if
I was what you thought you cuz you're a
good-looking older like middle age there
you go yeah there you go
we and I'm a young buck dude I am me
young you know what I realize 44 no you
know what I realized I'm young dude
that's what I realized
no I'm like what the [ __ ] why do I have
Benjamin buttons disease no I think I
got to a certain point where all of a
sudden I started walking back house dude
no cuz your face I've decided is you
have your you that you're what you
indent where your eyes are so you have
an hourglass face which to me to mean
only to me I'm not trying to be a dick
about it okay but if you look at your
face in a vacuum
yeah without your personality right
personality and good hair but just the
face structure
yeah is revolting
no way you're saying I got a peanut head
in the worst way and it's it's it's a
marvel that you get away with it
rah yeah don't lose your hair no I'm
gonna I don't like I say what I can't
wait to do a [ __ ] role where I just
gotta shave this [ __ ] off play peanut no
I mean uh where the [ __ ] is peanut there
he is
and they go like this why are his
shoulders so broad cuz now I get it
right because then I get it now there's
hairs out there I get a lot of months
around hey bring up his Instagram
Ellison I can't help it
that's all things apply in the man it's
out of nowhere and it just out of
nowhere and it was like it
it was literally at like 1:00 in the
morning and it just said I have a
swimmer's body and I go dude and then I
just got a picture of him with a shirt
off well like huh like that well look at
him just keep going I want to see well
yeah there I don't know just keep going
like that he key thing that was funny
the key key thing I did it oh yeah
there's the be various and there's
certain Peters there is so happy with
you you get a lot of a lot of female
attention on that [ __ ] post bro chicks
dude don't care man you know he's so hip
he's got a rope now do you approve of
the Rope for a belt do you do a Chris
yeah what kind of jeans are those bro
caller genes are guys we had the same
coat on last night you know how much it
cost I don't know I don't know you know
why
[Music]
yeah let's all do there [ __ ] you guys
yeah okay [ __ ] this old dude just like
my social studies time looking man hey
you [ __ ] what is that what is that yeah
dude what the [ __ ] bro what are you
doing man what are you doing taking why
you dressed so [ __ ] regular because
I'm a [ __ ] regular man no it's not us
trading in that sense I'm not some
Wallflower all right I'm not some
decorating for these [ __ ] sunglasses
on dude take them off your bird take
them off I won't I won't hey happy bird
take them off right now don't call me
happy you're a happy bird take off right
now Harry dude what are you guys talking
about before I even got here probably
some [ __ ] like some matter I could beat
any I think 95% of men holding your
whole career and your whole persona is
wrapped up in your hair what happens if
it falls out dude I play interesting
rolls are playing interest are you
losing your head get real fat or I get
why mean you lose hair you get older but
you know lose you're not going bald
I mean I less hair than I have yeah but
you don't have a receding hairline no I
mean it's back there I got a bit you
know what it is I have a big forehead
period which sucks so if I lose any hair
I start looking more like I [ __ ] you
know yeah it's over what what let's do
some carnival you got small head you're
smart I do I know you got a smile as a
forehead first you got a small girl
almond head don't write it oh yeah I put
some cocoa on it don't you be
condescending I'm not but I'll put some
cocoa guests on this pocket some cocoa
why the [ __ ] it's so Noah do you roll I
don't you're sweet James Dean it's
either shirts me no that's actually not
that big of a [ __ ] deal bro rolling
up your sleeve I don't hold it up it's
stitched that way don't wear those
stitch shirts like that
Tuesday eyeing that this [ __ ] guy
yeah this guy
guy don't hit him I've had this shirt
before I started lifting weights you
know don't you don't have to show off
your your weird arms skinny fat my
skinny fat yeah look I'm on matter how
jiggles look he's soft you have you have
to credit / annoyed them you did a
decrepit flesh no you have to general
you have the flesh of a degenerate can I
be honest with you you have the skin the
look and the flesh of a pervert and I
may email listen of a street of a street
pervert not even a high-class pervert
you look like a street pervert whatever
dude you do you look like a [ __ ]
street chin hit a suit current events
sorry man look at that look at how
good-looking that was that's what they
look like but much bigger you look good
huh you're a good actor hmm you're a
good actor yeah yeah I mean I've been
doing it for 25 years so don't say just
say good right so I'm there's a chance I
could be great right if I open up if I
really want it no but they say go they
go like you they go in casting rooms
they'll be like we get Bryan Callen and
then you know after everyone's like
who's that they go like now listen amigo
like no he was like that's because I get
so lost in the character you don't know
me from one role to the next and here's
the other thing you know that I can dig
deep right I can dig deep there I am is
the Joker no Ryan you're you're not you
don't play the Joker Joker Moog that's
what is okay that's lying right so that
picture is lying right that would just
be a clickbait picture yeah
or or I'm playing the Joker though it
says Bryan Callen cast in Joker right
there on the side everyone in okay I
don't know okay right well you know cuz
you did it right yeah at any point in
the shooting did you
alright nevermind dude you know you lie
so nevermind yeah I've done a lot of big
movies dude
there you go there I am no that's not
you that's Joaquin Phoenix how do you
know that oh so I guess is of his face I
guess that picture is a lot is lying
right yeah cuz it's from we have a very
sunny animated times.com argue with them
right right
okay argue with them don't be a dick but
my [ __ ] do I get the most hits on
your podcasts I don't know I do Jenny
does I mean maybe if you had [ __ ]
Elon I have you had like anybody like
Elon Musk but when it comes to c-listers
like me see this does like me you get
massive hits what are you what what
level I'm an acapella I'm a mama imma
like at all imma like a Barrett you're
not a Sikh I'm a baritone ba ba ba ba
nobody I don't do duets I really don't I
do solo pronounces no I don't do it I
didn't see if you're singing I go like
this like that but when you stop I go
no see you sound like a dog but I sound
like a [ __ ] dog
dude I had Leah's gonna be 40 and those
things are gonna die gonna die your hair
falls out nope my dad's got a fire hair
so did everyone in my family hope your
dad will just money because the well is
gonna run dry no no I mean yeah yeah
fine you become famous rough this like
have you become don't say or more use
the word more in that sense well no if
you get like more like if you jump off a
bottle fame but what if you become it if
you become somebody that they want for
serious dramatic roles more roles then
what then what's gonna happen you just
get real mad you've met you're gonna get
punched up don't know but like in you
like you can't help it it's like a
visceral no you're like I'm on Chris
when you get a big role dude do you
hesitate to tell Brian you sent me
I've had my share and I've turned my
share down don't look like that's
something all right
don't raise your eyebrow okay okay they
have a mind of its own but okay don't
don't do that okay I browse calm when
you say okay all right don't [ __ ]
have your caterpillars go crazy all
right but so I've turned roles down I've
chosen to keep my career okay where it
is right right like you like the private
life I have not fallen victim to the
public embrace of celebrity oh because
it keeps me focused and I do what it is
that I want to do stay humble I'd like
to spend your pudding on it yeah no I
think it's a good thing it's all about
being positive
okay there's guys when they come in the
Comedy Store you know I'm saying like
your own with a cow [ __ ] yeah man like
when you walked in one's like yeah
yeah oh cool thanks there's that guys
like Bryan Callen okay you're gonna you
took the compliment right over right
over I got offered that that role that I
did um in for the movie from and that's
a sony picture I mean that's a huge move
it's a big but it's a drama so I was
like well good on the director from in
the Berlin dining you could do it it's
also a leap of faith because the
character you're playing now I mean make
sense when I look at you it makes sense
okay yeah like when I heard them like oh
yeah that's Chris yeah yeah actually
cause I know you're thinking we're
thinking but it's not a hero it's not a
superhero no that's not what they're
thinking yeah they were you'll never
play a superhero really dude really dude
yeah you don't think so dude yeah I
don't mind my [ __ ] striations say
otherwise don't you don't have strike
white zone dude I do have them in my
chest if I say whereas it would be
ridiculous I did [ __ ] dips yesterday
between two chairs and that's not that's
not a brag I know but I did until I
dropped practically oh you did seven
ignored my kids sit in the chair yeah
they were who have you seen laughs nope
they want absolutely like I was like
move daddy gets worse than me I got work
to do and then I send you guys my
workout just - yeah it's don't you guys
get a little cut to comfortable well you
know I could eat your ass you're dead
lifting a smartcard it was too heavy it
was too heavy and I don't like 2501
got a car and he's got terrible shoes
and he's eating oatmeal on some Jordan
Air Force Ones the original no those are
the original Jays yeah it just bothers
me that you guys get it I hate that
Chris does this he goes did we start
yeah all right what you hate yo show me
your shoes and you go they're so dope
they oh yeah well you're a grown man
you're 36 man I'm young you're 36 I'll
let you know when I'm gonna adult how's
that
yo yet hard I'll let you know when I'm
gonna thought who's that look I'm a kid
bro I know I'm just a little pup when do
you think Oh cuz we were talking so you
know I mean we're the [ __ ] experience
comes into me and then I [ __ ] shoot
it out right so I'm like this just
happened to me and then all of a sudden
I've got
new minutes ago on stage dang it dang it
dang it a banger than the danged a
tonsil audience is like how do I [ __ ]
did I workout today and then the next
day dude I get a lot of times I get [ __ ]
you know emails none a lot of emails
from a bad way ya know in the galactus
dude I thought I was like did I workout
yesterday I'm like oh yeah I went to the
Chris D'Elia show because my [ __ ]
core come on his [ __ ] solid right now
you know you shoot your food eat it
I'll just plants plants don't run I grab
a mini - yeah I'm with Chris on this all
just me yeah I'll just be careful there
that's why you I would go hunt and you
would stay behind and you would mash no
dude I'll tell you what I would do you
know I would be doing mash then I would
go raw water from the well no and you'd
have you would go out you would go home
unpaired how about this you present me
with it what about this said yeah big
there'd be a big welcoming back party
you'd have a dress angle honey no that's
actually not what will be happening you
know will be happening while you're out
hunting I would be up in your girl's
guts oh wow about that
Oh home by leaving it in Oh leaving my
guy and then guess what and making me
raise your raise my kid coping why's
your look like oh alright well your car
that's you in four years okay yeah okay
anyway I'm your dad Oh more uh you are
so awful here and you know it you're a
ghastly human being leaving you know
what I am bro what sneaky huh that's
what everybody needs to know Chris
sneaky delete yeah 27 on it well I mean
you know between you'll be between 25
and 40 years all right cuz I think when
you get 40 you're in a different
brackets
Oh Brian God what him [ __ ] are you
saying
sometimes just take a [ __ ] guess see
you're saying what we're saying only
with way too many words and after we
said it yeah I got like um no oh
like busting angle yeah and your
shoulders right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]